[Music]
value associated with any of the Arts
because do you use anything in your hand
for your job yes
this is very important you are going to
the San Regis Hotel
you are going to keep an eye on him
it may and make sure he paints
hello James
welcome to dollyland oh my God
Jesus Christ Superstar who are you
I'm James Linton Gala is the power she
does the deals and handles the money
give us money we give you a painting
whatever you do he must not insult her I
need a new assistant I will borrow this
boy because if you do you are out
[Music]
great
I need many beautiful houses is he
getting any work done
we open in three weeks how is it working
for darling we need money it's like I
landed on another planet I belong I need
you
what's going on it's complicated so this
is a fig
he was still from darling
is a genius
I need her
to push me
tell you there are bad things going on
around you
I give you everything Felix don't take
him seriously anymore I'm just trying to
tell you the truth
it frightens me
and this is the basis of my inspiration
the paint
disappears becomes reality sometimes it
is so hard being dully